i guess my question is this i i think
it's a it's it's a
it's a two-part question a is this
important to figure out yes
this is clearly important 66 percent of
democrats
yes yeah
find out what happened here sure yeah
unbiased uncontrolled like let's figure
out
but b
what relevancy does it have for future
elections meaning is this help the trump
campaign get elected again in 2024 does
this hurt like that's that's what i'm
saying because because then then then
then the same question can be asked in a
following way uh a
do we have to know go back to 2016 when
everybody was saying russia russia
russia
you know
do we have to find out if trump was
linked to russia okay and then b but who
cares if it did you know what uh are we
going to get out of it if we did find
out it's the same question but everybody
in the media wanted to know it i mean
there's there's clips if you want to do
greatest hits don lemon saying all they
talk about is a durham investigation
durham investigation derma investigation
it's out now
you know
rachel maddow's like everybody's relying
on the durham investigation there's
nothing it's just a conspiracy theory
okay you know
morning joe they keep talking about the
durham investigation but there's nothing
they're relying on they addressed this
specifically head-on on morning joe
today i don't know if you heard what
they said they had an expert come on and
really
sort of diffuse the argument it's
something you should watch right look
what i'm saying is this diffuse the
argument meaning it's not a big deal
exactly that's this this and this was
not on the news two days ago when i kind
of was like hey what the hell is going
on here
it's just there's so much out there and
there's only so much bandwidth someone
can take i'm saying from the mind of an
individual voter
so how many people actually voted a
certain way because of benghazi as an
example maybe the emails especially when
comey came out and kind of said it was a
sloppy job so i tell you there are a
couple things here because it's it's not
even just about say the pure partisan
aspect the the democrats it's also about
the media so why is morning joe out
there doing well number one they just
they're unbridled trump hatred except
when joe and mika were visiting us a
couple days before the campaign in 2016
and we're all buddies then but now we're
not but that's a whole another
conversation but the fact that they're
they have to go out there and
essentially they hate trump so they want
to go and say this isn't true they want
to defend themselves knowing that they
spent hundreds if not thousands of hours
of doing broadcasts saying russia russia
russia we're going to get this guy and
when you go into some of the especially
the hyperbole that we saw i mean look i
was a cnn commentator in 2017 and 2018
how many russia segments did i waste my
life doing on cnn uh and of course we
find out that it was all
uh two too many of these you know six on
one panels to uh you know to
to name um
so here's the thing going forward we got
to make sure that the media is held
accountable that they don't get
completely snookered uh and taking down
these rabbit holes on future things
because as we saw from russia russia
russia i.e moeller impeachment one
impeachment two
if trump runs again in 2024 which i
think he does they're gonna have the
next russia russia russia they're gonna
have some next thing they come up with
here's our chance to finally beat the
orange man uh we're gonna come up with
some new crackpot thing that the media
all goes running like lemmings
they don't go and actually do their own
work they just go out there and try to
drive ratings and and get clicks and
we're going to have the same thing
happen again listen it's it's a
this line
what's the big deal what's the big deal
what's the big deal with emails
everybody does it what's the big deal
everybody does it what's the big deals
both sides uh uh meddle in elections
what's the big deal no listen the big
deal is that the american people believe
these guys can get away with murder
literally
and if you want to have people have
trust in a system there's got to be
accountability period left right middle
the part i was going to ask him with
barr
why why they didn't ask the question why
didn't they do the investigation he said
the only thing is i wish i would have
done this investigation earlier you were
taught my bar you know where i went to
i went to the area maybe they didn't
want to do the investigation because
they deep down and psyched out maybe
there was some kind of connection to
russia do you know what i'm saying i
like the fear for borrowing saying the
internal voices the the billboards
trump's camp we're like dude let's just
kind of not do because what if there is
and we don't you think they were
drinking some of the the the idol media
cool yeah i i don't know if they were or
not i'm not saying they were or not all
i'm saying is it was such an effective
campaign that got his own side to
believe it like
imagine if
everybody decides to go on a smear
campaign about you and we work together
right
and i've seen how you are
for how many years now three years of
you know being around each other i kind
of know who you are right
and they say and all of a sudden i'm
like yeah maybe he is like that maybe he
is this maybe he is that and i start
second guessing based on what i've
personally witnessed from you right and
i start buying into that the scary thing
is if trump's own camp started kind of
talking beyond closed doors saying maybe
this guy did something with russia would
he even tell us anyways if he did he
probably wouldn't tell us if he did you
know he's so much about wanting to win
so maybe bard didn't want to investigate
it i don't know again i i never heard i
never heard any of that for all the time
i'm not i'm not saying i'm right or i'm
wrong only thing is
if you were so certain that something
was going on with spine why the hell
wouldn't you start earlier because i'm
going to tell you because
barr
is keep in mind bar was attorney general
before uh in the final days of beast
yes he was attorney general yeah 38 or
39 i wouldn't say so he's been a he's a
heavyweight we know he's heavyweight and
he's been around for a long time there
is a
for many people in washington who are
trump allies uh at least or were trump
allies where they might be there's this
push and pull of certain people really
overthink and worry about other people
are going to say about them are they
going to be allowed at the mcclane
country club what's going to happen
while i'm in uh and
bar lives in mclean what happens when
i'm you know going to these events and
people see me at the parties are they
going to think that uh oh this guy's
unhinged or he did something politically
charged uh using his abused his
government power for a political reason
i think this was a he knew that
something stunk he knew something was
bad he didn't want it to happen 2020
become a campaign issue and he
overthought this one and actually guess
what it probably was a campaign issue
because if the spying went on into
trump's administration and he had to
waste multiple years of his
administration pushing back on these
russia rumors it most certainly was a
2020 issue that's where i would just
that's that's my thought and how much
credibility do you think john durham has
i mean he seems to be uh
i probably can't i just i i don't know
him um i think that uh i my concern also
too is that the longer we get past trump
leaving office that people start to say
why are we going back to something in
the past to your point that you raise
like why does this matter now is this
okay put the one person but should we
really be making a big deal the longer
you get away from it the less likelihood
there is of being true accountability
yeah i mean listen every day
for god knows how long everybody was
watching the oj trial case
right okay
okay okay
we're watching the o.j trial case right
okay how long did that last
how many times a day was it on tv how
many hours did it was on tv biggest
story so it looks like 94. let me ask
you a question let me ask you a question
why
who cares so let's let's take your
position
who cares whether he did or let's just
you know who cares if he did
how does that affect my life actually
think about it how did what oj did
to his ex-wife affect your life
think about that
but no actually think about it directly
indirectly you know you go down a
slippery slope but go to murder two
people you probably want accountability
so we
are more concerned about holding
citizens
accountable
than those who create laws and have
control of the us government that we pay
taxes to
and yeah it's okay year and a half
watching oj every day of course we have
to do that but year and a half of trying
to catch the bad guy if there was any
manipulation behind this with the
government guys we just got to move on
we just got to move on because oj's
trial was way more important than
hillary clinton and this kind of stuff
no
to be clear i think that's why i kind of
get i know you're not you need to have
some accountability yeah but does this
move the needle moving i think
that's my only question no no forget
election i don't even think election
forget about the election it's got
nothing to do with election you know
what it's going to do here's what it's
going to do it's going to one
you know get the next guy that's
thinking about doing it to say
it ain't as easy as it used to be before
kind of kick back guys because the price
is that big
and number two what it's going to do is
it's going to get people to say okay you
know all these guys that have been
telling me that they're doing all this
stuff for me in my favor yeah you were
full of and i'm sorry my vote
matters a lot and the same way
barry goldwater what he did
he
when they went after him you know four
years later the african-american vote
went from 64 percent democrat to 92
democrat yeah that that that was a
consequence the price had to be paid and
the american people today have to know
because their vote matters today more
than ever before there's one other thing
i'd also put a kind of a finer point on
this i think
public trust in government institutions
is probably an all-time low right now i
know trust in certainly for congressman
that is definitely for congressman
aspects of federal law enforcement
and obviously there are all sorts of
concerns with elections and things like
that i think we need to make sure that
the public has confidence that all
aspects of law enforcement of national
security type agencies
that leaders who are in the white house
so they have that confidence of what
actually to what extent government power
is being abused uh to what extent the
people who are writing laws is this
gonna be allowed to happen again is this
all essentially just do we have people
throw in the towel just say this whole
system is rigged um i think that's
terrible for democracy it's a big part
of the reason why trump won because
people thought the whole system was
rigged and it was stacked against people
and
certainly you look at stagflation lack
of wage growth over the last couple of
decades and you'd say yeah ever since
nafta and you say that's definitely the
case we have to do something here in the
country to restore some aspect of trust
and confidence because right now it's
terrible i mean look as someone who uh
you know grew up as kind of you know the
the g-men you know the fbi like these
are these are the good guys i mean i
mean i have a number of people i went to
college with for example the one in the
fbi and you know they're always like you
know the fbi those are the good guys
like yeah like we're the ones who are
stopping the bad guys but now what's
happened over the last couple years with
the internal politics and seeing the
swirl um
people have
many people that have a negative view of
our law enforcement or some of these
these government agencies and i think
that's terrible or even just the legal
system as a whole and we got to restore
some of that trust yeah i think i think
i had gordon chang gone who knows
he lived in australia for 20 some years
lawyer yeah and he says in 1980
something there was only four law
schools in china
and what what the law does it increases
trust that people cannot be bullied now
we all know i've paid
i don't know in the last 12 years 10
million dollars to legal fees not
because of lawsuits but because of
contract this contract that contract
this and every time you talk to a lawyer
for 10 minutes that was a two-hour
conversation here's 1200 bucks so i have
my own opinions about lawyers but yeah
don't get started
the legal system
allows you to walk outside and feel
safe the legal system allows me to drive
in the streets safer
the legal system allows me to
have my kids go out and they're not
around me i'm not overly paranoid
because i trust the legal system there's
there's a certain
certain safety and security the legal
system brings to you right
they say many times women are with a man
they want to feel secure and safe right
when she sits next to you you feel safe
you're like okay there's a certain
safety that you're bringing to me okay
that's a role that we gotta play many
times i think that's a legal system and
i think the importance about this is the
american people are gonna say okay there
is law and order in america that's all
there is there is i've had one too many
speeding tickets i've deserved every one
of them my license has been suspended a
couple of times i was speeding i
deserved it i'm not going to sit and
tell you i was and every time the cop
one time a cop pulls me over and he says
do you know how fast you were going i
said yeah much faster than you couldn't
catch out
and he starts laughing i said what is
the matter with you i said bro i got so
many tickets man what do you want to do
if you're going to give it to me give it
to me but i'm just having fun with you
says you know what is he always like
this and jen's like i'm so sorry but he
is he's always like this you know what
just can you slow down i'm like i slowed
down i'm so sorry i said just go and i
left never gave me a ticket well you
didn't slow down no of course i didn't
slow down but i left but i did slow down
for five miles you have to you have to
respect
that we gotta talk about accountability
i got pulled over for this like two
years ago for talking on my cell phone
right and and the officer is like why
were you on your cell phone like i was
talking to the president
and he just looks at me he's like huh
it's like yeah he's talking to the
president he's like and then he kind of
paused for him and he's like why did you
choose a bluetooth because it was
cutting out and i was like there's a
present so i had to like you know talk
to him and he's kind of paused i'm in
arlington virginia right so no i got the
ticket no that didn't give you that yeah
that didn't it didn't help
i probably could have said great story i
should have said it was like i was on
the phone with hillary clinton yeah oh
you know what oh sorry sir can i escort
you to your house you're going to be
safe exactly sir i was organizing uh the
next black lives matter uh protest and
um you may have been safer especially
where you ran yeah i guarantee myself
did he believe you
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]